alors il y avait des votes au congrès
pour le congrès hier soir au sénat
chambre des représentants il y avait
aussi beaucoup de référendum et il faut
en parler
geneviève parce que rien qu'hier y en
avait 100 55 ans fait qu'ils ont eu lieu
dans 37 états et pendant la campagne il
s'est dépensé plus d'un milliard de
dollars pour les campagnes du oui ou du
non
quelques sujets qui était présentée aux
électeurs américains
d'abord le cannabis on connaît bien ça
ici depuis que celle égaliser et bien
hier soir les résidents du michigan ont
décidé que oui nous allons aussi
légaliser le cannabis à des fins
récréatives
on peut même cultiver jusqu'à dix plants
de potes chez soi quand on parle
maintenant vous avez quand même dix
états qui ont légalisé aux etats unis
c'est important de le mentionner quand
on parle du cannabis à des fins
thérapeutiques cette fois ci est bien le
missouri et lus tard ont décidé de huy
également octroyé cette légalisation
sous certaines conditions ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a trente deux états
américains qui ont dit oui pour le côté
thérapeutique c'est quand même pas mal
autre sujet évidemment qui divise
beaucoup c'est toujours l'avortement
c'est un sujet très chaud toujours
bouillant l'actualité eh bien
figurez-vous que hier soir lit à deux
états qui se sont prononcés sur la
question l'alabama et la virgine
occidentale en dix ans après tout le
foetus à des droits aussi et donc on
n'est plus maintenant obligés de
financer des cliniques d'avortement par
exemple donc on a décidé de reculer un
peu sur cette question là si on parle
maintenant de la floride ou bien il ya
quelque chose qui s'est passé hier soir
très intéressant donc référendum sur re
octroyer le droit de vote aux gens aux
criminels qui ont déjà purgé leur peine
c'est quand même important parce que ça
veut dire que pour la prochaine élection
il y a un bilan quatre cent mille
personnes qui se retrouvent comme
électeur évidemment majeur et puis aussi
afro américains en grande majorité
évidemment l'état de washington le
contrôle des armes à feu
évidemment on en parle encore dorénavant
il faudra avoir 21 ans et plus et il y
aura des vérifications d'antécédents
encore plus élaborée
alors des grands enjeux sociaux mais pas
seulement il y avait des choses disons
quoi plus pointus oui plus pointus plus
ciblées par exemple le tampon l'hygiène
féminine au nevada mais dit que noir est
dorénavant il y aura plus de taxe là
dessus si on parle maintenant des
courses de chiens et bien en floride ont
décidé que d'ici 2021 c'était interdit
donc terminée pour les livres y est si
on parle maintenant des poules
c'est important les poules pondeuses en
californie on l'a dit que dorénavant on
pourra plus les mettre en cage
libérons les petites cocottes et
dernière chose vous le reconnaissez
évidemment c'est moïse bien sûr et bien
en alabama à partir de maintenant il
faudra mettre les dix commandements dans
les endroits publics à gensac je parle
mais je pense à vous aviez mais bon et
des armes à feu aucun autre débat merci
beaucoup pour l'incarner